could not be more excited that on
peacock
on sunday night you can watch an nfl
playoff game
browns and steelers will be on nbc
sports as well as telemundo
but it's also available for you to see
right here on peacock and
calling that game uh along with al
michaels
as always uh is our friend here
on the rich eisen show thrilled is
always to have chris collinsworth on
such a big
nfl week how are you chris i'm good i
just want to
know how do i find somebody who
defecates
nickels to hang out that's all i want
well you sit next to a man who knows how
to invest them how does that sound how
does that sound no no
he ain't passing any of those nickels
out i want somebody who passes them out
i got it i got it yeah al michaels may
be the only uh broadcaster who's
checking his day trading during a
commercial break potentially if it's
anything like that unbelievable rich you
know as well as i do
yes he's wasting his time doing football
right he's just wasting his time i've
never seen a guy
that knows more about more stuff
than than al michaels and the stock
market i i watch some of those stock
market shows every once while i go
i don't need to watch this al knows way
more than those guys know about this
stuff
now look when when terry mcauley joined
your broadcast team chris you know
obviously he's
terrific at it and knowing the rule book
i thought
you already got a rules expert in the in
the booth his name is al michaels i mean
al knows
everything about everything from clock
management to whether this should be
challenged or not he knows that right on
the spot i mean that's al's specialty
you know yeah but but it's it turns into
talk radio up there like i
there's nothing i like better and i'll
do it during the broadcast i'll just go
you know i'll start rambling on about
the rules or something i go terry
and then here we go you know
then you know it's going to be like a
battle royal at that point
exactly it's it's so nice though having
terry up there in the booth like that
because it's
you know it's just just go hey what do
you got brother
well i mean you know you're part of an a
plus broadcast team chris collinsworth
here on the rich eisen show and before
we do get to the
the uh the playoffs uh you know i was
gonna do this last but we might as well
since we're talking about your broadcast
team right here and there
i mean talk about a story uh that plays
out right in front of you
that's not just about the final score or
anything x's and o's um it was
what we saw on sunday night football in
that fourth quarter
that started with the head scratcher of
of jalen hurts uh being told to go for
it on fourth
and four uh rather than kick a chip shot
field goal and that's when the craziness
began did you have any
concept throughout the week talking to
doug peterson that nate sutfeld would be
put into a game
that is in doubt in the fourth quarter
of game 256
chris um not that was in doubt we
actually
i think al asked that question he did
mention that sudfeld
um might get in the game
and that he deserved a chance and then
somebody al or freddie or somebody asked
the question well what happens if this
is
if it's a close game uh at the end would
you still do it and he's kind of
you know dug like oh yeah right so you
never knew for sure what was going on
um but then you know you just start
looking down there at the field and you
know you you've been in the booth you
know what it's like you can kind of tell
when
something's about to change down there
and we saw
jason kelsey and nate sutfield taking
some snaps and
like they are gonna do this you know
they're gonna they're gonna make this
change um and then every conspiracy
theory starts floating through your head
and you're trying to be fair but you're
trying to be honest and you're trying to
do
all kinds of different things there
so i mean it was a tough situation you
know there's no doubt about it we were
on a press call
yesterday getting ready for the the wild
card game and somebody asked me did i
get a call
either from the eagles or from the
league uh
based on my comments and i said no
i said you know i've gotten phone calls
in the past from
various people but i didn't over that no
i mean look uh
chris i mean you were just being honest
when you said you wouldn't do it like
you just
wouldn't be able to do what the eagles
either
asked of doug peterson or he did
uh on his own knowing what the plan was
as a group going into the game i mean
it was just and and and and i speak uh
you know sitting in a chair where i was
begging my team that i grew up in the
jets to tank
all 16 games on behalf of trevor
lawrence it's a very difficult fine line
but when it comes down to it
you know uh the league with nbc is
trying
and has built an outstanding uh property
in game 256
celebrating the competition of a
completed regular season
with hopefully the birth of a playoff
game right in front of everybody's eyes
and
it was just weird to see it turn into a
preseason week four chris
it was just a really weird feeling to
see i i think that's what it was for me
too it was because i watched the games
during the course of the day
as we're getting ready and i
i i was just so impressed i was so
impressed all year honestly i
really sincerely thought about buying
jet season tickets
after they i swear i did i was like you
know what
i go this to me personifies
everything i love about the nfl you can
talk about tanking you can talk
about all that but when those damn
players get on the field
they can't help themselves they're
playing right right
it's just built into their dna that they
are going for the win right and the jets
did it and
got they just couldn't help themselves
they had to win a couple of football
games
and i was so impressed with that i was
like i go that's awesome man that's what
this league's all about
and then you know there we were you know
at the end of the season
and all day long teams that were playing
for something
teams that were had to rest players
teams and all but the games were great
they were just
going at it they were just great all the
way down to the wire
um and so then you get to sort of this
celebrated moment
this this final game of the season
um and and i'm not i you know i i
can't i can't pass judgment on anybody i
don't know if this was an
decision i don't know if this is doug
just had seen things in practice
that you know he wanted nate sudfeld to
get a chance i i have no idea
but you know john madden had a great
saying
that you know you go in with a plan to
do your broadcast and then a football
game breaks out right
yeah and then you adjust you just adjust
to whatever
and i think and i was just and i always
try to put myself in that position right
if i were doug peterson could i have
made that move
and all i kept thinking was to myself
was
i couldn't have done this you know and i
was just sorry whatever just say it out
loud
you know that that was my innate feeling
now at the end of that was the fact that
the eagles lost that game did that
benefit
the philadelphia organization yeah you
know not just the first round pick is
going to move from whatever nine to six
your second round your third round you
know everything is going to move up
and so if you added up the ability to
move up three spots in
every round of the draft you probably
would have to give up
an early second round pick to justify
that and maybe even a first
pick you know for all i know so was it
did it benefit the organization
yes but i also think that you have to go
you know you're gonna have to explain
that to a lot of players you know that
that
something and maybe nothing was going on
maybe it's just
was pure and simple that nate sutfeld
had so impressed him in practice that
they wanted to give him a chance i don't
know i you know all i could do is react
to it as a human being
chris collins with sunday night football
right here on
the rich eisen show let us get to the
game at hand for you
and al and the rest of the crew on
sunday night browns and
steelers let's start with the browns
it's thursday i don't know if you've
already spoken to coaches or if you plan
um if you do have anything with
stefanski lined up or alex van pelt and
how you expect this to all play out on
the play calling front for an
organization that's been waiting for
this opportunity for 18 years
chris yeah well if i if i had had those
conversations yet i wouldn't be telling
you but i
know absolutely nothing i'm sergeant
schultz on this okay
so i can tell you now what i think um
i don't think it'll be a huge deal
because there's time
to adjust you know when they played the
jets
earlier this year and 24 hours before
the game
uh they don't have any of their wide
receivers available that's a tough gig
right that's that's hard now you have to
make truly last second
sort of adjustments but kevin stefanski
is going to be in with mike preefer
uh and and the whole coaching staff alex
van pelt who will end up calling the
plays
and and they'll build a plan and who
actually calls those plays
you know as well as i do that doesn't
make that much difference plus for the
most part it's baker
once he gets a line of scrimmage you
know going all right this is run pass
this is kill
this is you know check with me you know
there's most of that stuff goes on at
the line of scrimmage now so
um you know i i don't think it'll be a
huge deal because of the fact
uh that they have it now what is sort of
a huge deal
uh in my mind is uh joel petonio not
being able to play
right this is an offensive line in
cleveland that uh has the two
best guards it's the best guard tandem
in football wyatt tellers come out of
nowhere
to be the best guard in football and but
tonio was right behind him
plus petonio has been on that team when
they were
garbage right when they just couldn't
beat anybody
so you really feel for him not being
able to play in this one but there's no
question the biggest
difference in any unit in the nfl from
one season the next
is what the browns had on their
offensive line a season ago
and what they have now so now obviously
we will see chubb we'll see hunt we'll
see
we'll see that running game uh the best
of their ability
let's flip the script to the steelers
now before we start
just matching them up together here um
you
were you were there in thanksgiving week
you
you
had five days in pittsburgh waiting for
that game to be played between the
the steelers and the ravens so you you
have seen firsthand
the uh chess pieces of the steelers
thrown up in the air and that was just
one of two times
happened obviously earlier in the season
with the titans with covid
and then after that thanksgiving game
when they finally did play it and did
beat the ravens even though
uh tomlin said that they sucked in that
game us sucking was the
was the answer to a question of why were
all those drop balls in that game that
you still won
then they lost three in a row so what do
you think
this steelers team is coming in um
off of a game where they rested starters
but a good half against
the colts that did actually get them
through into the division
how do you assess this team after that
big old setup i gave you
chris well first of all it wasn't
thanksgiving week it was thanksgiving
month in pittsburgh so
that's the way i it was unbelievable
that game just refused to be played
from thursday to wednesday it was a full
week to get that game played
um but you know the pittsburgh steelers
i think are the toughest team to try to
figure out coming into the season and in
many ways
the script is almost flipped at least
when it comes to these two offenses
you know it always felt like the
cleveland browns were kind of gripping
to for an identity and what are they
going to be and
you know now they've got this great
offensive line and they can run the
football with two tremendous backs and
a good young receiver in this donovan
people's jones has kind of come out of
nowhere and ever since
odell beckham got hurt they sort of
started spreading the wealth
and i think build build an offense in
the passing game but it's really built
around this running game and around uh
this offensive line whereas the
pittsburgh steelers forever
at least since i've been playing against
them and calling their games
there's always been this team that come
fourth quarter and they play renegade
over the loud speakers
and when they have to just pound the
football they can pound
it down your throat for the final seven
minutes of the game
and hold on to a four point lead and now
they're a quick release short
passing game kind of a team
but what we saw in the colts game was
they were really struggling that was the
worst
first half of offense i have ever seen
from a pittsburgh team against the colts
the worst
and they followed it up with all these
big plays in the second half and somehow
came back
from 24 to 7 and won the game
so you know but they had to hit big
plays so i think it's going to be a
little bit of that
again you know the steeler running game
has really struggled this season
after the first five or six weeks or so
uh
and now it's really going to be on these
big play receivers claypool and
washington
deontay johnson and juju they have to
make plays down the field
to keep this offense cranking so let's
put them together and you
with the the pro football focus numbers
that you
have at your disposal because that's
your organization and it's just so
terrific
nfl network using the numbers too so um
putting it all together
give me somebody we're not thinking of
give me somebody that you think on
sunday night is going to be
someone to watch for that we're not
talking about
right now chris what do you got for me
yeah it's
it's an interesting question um probably
adrian claiborne um miles garrett
is obviously the featured attraction
he's been really
sort of struggling though with the the
covid
um disease that he had and trying to
catch his breath i think he's finally
starting to see miles garrett come back
but olivier vernon who really had a
great second half of the season
towards achilles in that game the other
day on the opposite side
adrian claiborne um is a good player you
know you remember him in atlanta i
remember
several different places but he's much
more of a big
powerful bull rushing kind of guy
um which which might play to their
advantage because ben gets rid of the
ball
so quickly you basically he's going to
have to go through
alejandro villanueva to get to
roethlisberger and maybe
create a little bit of pressure so that
opposite uh
players is going to be key but then you
know
all the guys coming back in their
secondary whether it's
denzel ward if he can make it back kevin
johnson if he can make it back andrew
sendejo
have all missed some time either with
cova concussions whatever the case
and that's going to be the match up the
matchup is going to be pittsburgh's
receivers
against the secondary from the cleveland
browns you don't figure the pressure is
going to get there because ben hasn't
let it get there all season
but i think that'll be the matchup
before i let you go chris um let's
quickly talk about the
saturday night game on nbc called by our
colleagues mike tarico and tony dungy
and to me this is the most fascinating
uh
of the weekend quite frankly because
you've got tom brady
playing at the top of his game age 43
for the bucks who all season long we're
wondering when is the offense going to
look like what we're expecting it to
and you could say about taking on
atlanta twice in detroit and that's what
brady and the offense should have looked
like but
a lot of these shoulda games didn't look
like that way for the bucks all year
long
and then here comes the washington
football team and the guy who's going to
be trying to one and done tom brady is a
unicorn of a beast
interestingly enough from ohio state
with michigan at the quarterback
position
in chase young who basically said bring
him on and
i can't wait for it and i i think this
is going to be
highly competitive and i'm wondering
what you think of this matchup
chris um i i i think it's going to be
really interesting
and while the focal point is going to be
tom brady and the washington defensive
line you know montez sweat and jonathan
allen drawn paint those guys are
fantastic
but they do it with a four-man rush you
know i mean basically they're gonna come
our guys are better than your guys and
we're gonna try and cover it up on the
back end and there's a lot to cover up
on the back end whether mike evans plays
or not
you know this is a good bunch and i i
think gronkowski was
was took a while to get his feet
underneath him early in the season he
had a bad
shoulder he wasn't blocking the way that
he had been uh and for the most part of
his career but he's getting healthy
antonio brown's been hot you know he's
just been hot
god one's starting to get going here a
little bit uh we know about evans and
hopefully you know
scotty miller so this is a bunch that
they can do
quite a bit but for me the more
interesting side of the ball right now
is alex smith and what
the tampa bay box will do defensively
todd bowles and
his guys over there if you watched the
green bay game earlier this year
i mean they jumped out the green bay
jumped out to a 10-0 lead and basically
the buccaneers blitzed them into
submission i i've never seen the
the packers struggle against a blitz
like
that and alex smith we saw in the game
uh
last week that you know he's still
really struggling
with that calf injury you know a guy
that used to be able to move around
so well and of course all the 17
surgeries and all that kind of stuff
um so i'm
99.9 positive that
they're going to be blitzing him to try
and move him off the spot we saw the
impact that it had in that
game a week ago and if mobility becomes
a factor
do we end up seeing uh taylor heineke
you know that's the
that's the the x factor for me in this
game and how healthy terry mclaurin is
mclauren had a touchdown last week
but i think he was still struggling on
that ankle a little bit so maybe he's a
week
healthier than that so we shall see
chris
thanks for the call man um happy new
year to you and yours can't wait to hear
you and al on the call on sunday night
thanks
thanks for joining today appreciate it
you got it buddy happy new year
right back at you that's chris
collinsworth the one and only hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here